if you had to guess which would could be
first achieved first light speed travel
or teleportation so teleportations like
they did on Star Trek you get like
wobbly make sure you know you're
somewhere else but haven't peep
scientists already teleported light
isn't that a thing that somebody did in
a lab just everybody now first of all as
far as we know missing out on company
there is a portal game with guys
shooting holes of worms or whatever it
is where have I been
yeah where have you been a Jace I'm on
the government payroll missed out on a
lot of things bill I did well like some
guy teleported no no cause that'd be bad
person did silsila start with the first
one you right now we don't know of any
way to send something that has mass
beyond up to the speed of light right
right now there may be a whole other
physics yet to be discovered perhaps
this questioner will be the person that
makes the discovery yeah he's got to
stop playing the game portal yeah yeah
and go back to physics class and then a
second thing teleportation where you
turn mass into pure and not me no I was
gonna talk about mine be an example then
you call on us and we know you can turn
the hassle you know into pure energy
beam him down to what we generally refer
to as the planet
and then he's reconstituted that would
be converting mass into energy back in a
mess could be done but consider equals
mc-squared
it's a tremendous amount of energy to
convert even a small amount of mass into
something well so it may happen so maybe
just a piece of corn still start with
something into a person yeah or should
we start with just one element well I
think if you can get anything a carbon
atom would be pretty extraordinary even
hydrogen but in that sense you're saying
teleportation is potentially
theoretically possible before it's just
shooting from the hip yeah but go into
the light right now I take either one
how far you gonna teleport there she
light speed travel you Jim get you
places quickly yes I'm not sure about
the telephone we go to college are we
going to Mars with this I think we got a
feeling I got a feeling we needed light
speed first you might set up Austin but
teleports and we go yeah boss we can get
there anyway yeah so I'm gonna teleport
you to Mars you're gonna get this a
there's no place to go right B no one
else's parents there exactly I think we
need like speed travel first check the
place out well here's not asking what we
need first he's asking what's more
realistic in the a I don't know I'm not
a Swami
sounds like teleportation and thinks
early so still says yeah I take either
one I'd rather Lightspeed try let's go
fast let's enjoy it
alright let's punch it let's enjoy that
let's enjoy the ride